RESTORING ORDER, THAT’S THE
FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S ANGLE.
ALL PEOPLE OF GOOD FAITH AGREE
THAT WHAT HAPPENED TO GEORGE
FLOYD WAS HEINOUS AND DEPRAVED,
IT WAS MURDER.
BUT THAT’S NOT WHAT WE ARE
SEEING ON OUR VIOLENT STREETS.
WE ARE NOT SEEING OUTRAGE REALLY
EXPRESSED ABOUT THAT.
AND THAT’S NOT WITH THE
CRIMINALS AND THE DOMESTIC
TERRORISTS ARE PERPETRATING AS
THEY USE MR. FLOYD’S KILLING TO
TRY AND MURDER AMERICA.
EARLIER IN THE DAY, FLOYD’S OWN
BROTHER ISSUED A CALL FOR PEACE.
>> IF I’M OUT OF HERE MESSING UP
MY COMMUNITY, THEN WHAT ARE YOU
ALL DOING?
WHAT ARE Y’ALL DOING?
Y’ALL DOING NOTHING.
BECAUSE THAT’S NOT GOING TO
BRING MY BROTHER BACK AT ALL.
IT MAY FEEL GOOD FOR THE MOMENT
JUST LIKE WHEN YOU DRINK, BUT
WHEN IT COMES DOWN, YOU’RE GOING
TO WONDER WHAT YOU DID.
>> Laura: BUT THIS ISN’T WHAT
ANTIFA WANTS OR CARES ABOUT AND
IT’S NOT WHAT OTHER RADICAL
ELEMENTS WANT.
THEY WANT WAR.
THEY WANT TO TEAR DOWN WHAT TOOK
US ALMOST 250 YEARS TO BUILD,
LITERALLY AND FIGURATIVELY.
THE PRESIDENT TONIGHT REAFFIRMED
HIS DUTY TO DEFEND THE
CONSTITUTION.
>> MY FIRST AND HIGHEST DUTY AS
PRESIDENT IS TO DEFEND OUR GREAT
COUNTRY AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
I SWORE AN OATH TO UPHOLD THE
LAWS OF OUR NATION AND THAT IS
EXACTLY WHAT I WILL DO.
>> Laura: NOW, NEW YORK
GOVERNOR ANDREW CUOMO, WHOSE
NURSING HOMES BECAME COVID’S
KILLING FIELDS, SAID HE’S NOT
GOING TO SEEK AND DOESN’T WANT
THE PRESIDENT’S HELP.
>> I WAS SHOCKED AT THE FORCE
THEY USED TO MOVE THE
PROTESTERS, WHO COULD NOT HAVE
BEEN MORE PEACEFUL.
CALLING OUT THE AMERICAN
MILITARY FOR A PHOTO
OPPORTUNITY.
THESE ARE YOUNG PEOPLE WHO STILL
HAVE IDEALISM AND WANT TO MAKE
THIS NATION BETTER, AND THAT’S A
GOOD INSTINCT, AND IT SHOULD BE
ENCOURAGED.
>> Laura: IT SHOULD BE
WE’VE BEEN SHOWING FOOTAGE
ALL-NIGHT OF WHAT WHAT THEY’RE
DOING THROUGHOUT MANHATTAN.
AND BY THE WAY, WHAT WE SAW,
SOME OF WHAT WE SAW IS WHAT I
SAW LAST NIGHT UP AND CLOSE AND
PERSONAL IN WASHINGTON, D.C.
THE PROTEST WASN’T VERY FOCUSED
ON THE HEINOUS INJUSTICE
COMMITTED AGAINST GEORGE FLOYD.
THERE WERE A FEW SIGNS IN THE
REFUGE DOOR TO GEORGE FLOYD
T-SHIRTS BUT THERE WAS NO
CANDLELIGHT VIGIL, THERE WAS NO
SINGING AND EMBRACING.
PEOPLE WERE TAKING SELFIES IN
FRONT OF SECRET SERVICE AGENTS,
WHOM THEY WERE MOCKING AND
SWEARING AT AND IN SOME CASES
SPITTING AT.
I’M NOT SURE WHAT ANY OF THAT
ACCOMPLISHED.
BUT THE VIOLENT AND EVENTUAL
ELEMENTS WERE FOCUSED ON
CREATING CHAOS, TERROR, AND FEAR
ACROSS AMERICA.
SO DON’T YOU DARE LIE TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE BY SAYING THAT
ANY OF THIS HAD ANYTHING TO DO
AT ITS VIOLENT CORE, WITH GEORGE
FLOYD.
FROM WHAT HIS FAMILY SAID,
GEORGE WAS NOT THAT KIND OF
PERSON.
HE WOULDN’T DO WHAT THESE PEOPLE
ARE DOING TONIGHT.
PEACEFUL PROTESTS ARE USUALLY
HELD, AS I SAID TO HANNITY,
DURING THE DAY.
AFTER ALL, WE KNOW THAT, BECAUSE
UNDER THE DARK OF NIGHT, UNDER
THE COVER OF DARKNESS, WE CAN’T
SEE WHO’S THROWING WHAT, WHO’S
STARTING WHAT FIRES LIKE THE ONE
THAT I SAW AS WE WERE LEAVING
THE SCENE AT THE HISTORIC
ST. JOHN’S CHURCH.
NOW, WE WALKED TO THE CAR SEEING
THESE HISTORIC HOTELS, BEAUTIFUL
BUILDINGS BOARDED UP, GRAFFITI
EVERYWHERE.
I FELT LIKE I WAS BACK IN IRAQ
IN 2006 AND FEBRUARY, EXCEPT I
ACTUALLY FELT A LOT SAFER ON THE
STREETS OF BAGHDAD THAN I DID AT
TIMES IN D.C. LAST NIGHT.
THE AIM OF THESE CRIMINAL
ENTERPRISES, INCLUDING ANTIFA,
BUT NOT LIMITED TO ANTIFA, IS TO
UNDERMINE CONFIDENCE IN OUR
INSTITUTIONS OF GOVERNMENT AT
ALL LEVELS, LOCAL, STATE, AND
FEDERAL.
THESE WANTON ACTS OF VIOLENCE
ARE PART OF A COORDINATED EFFORT
TO EVENTUALLY OVERTHROW THE
UNITED STATES GOVERNMENT.
IT’S WELL-FUNDED AND IT’S WELL
ORGANIZED ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
NO TWITTER WARNINGS, BY THE WAY,
FROM JACK DORSEY EVEN THOUGH
THEY SEEK NOTHING SHORT OF AN
OVERTHROW OF ALL THAT WE LOVE
AND BELIEVE IN.
AND ELIMINATION OF OUR
CONSTITUTION, BASICALLY ALL OF
OUR RIGHTS, INCLUDING THE
SECOND AMENDMENT, AND MUCH OF
THE FIRST.
THEY DON’T CARE ABOUT GEORGE
FLOYD.
THEY’RE USING AND ABUSING HIS
MEMORY TO CREATE MORE SUFFERING
AND MORE CHAOS.
IT’S LIKE ONE GIANT VIDEO GAME
TO SOME THESE FOLKS, BUT THEIR
CALL TO DUTY IS ONE OF
ANNIHILATION OF THE COUNTRY THAT
WE ALL LOVE.
NOWHERE DOES THIS ALL COME FROM?
I WAS THINKING ABOUT THIS TODAY
TALKING TO FRIENDS AND DOWN THE
ROAD IN D.C., WHERE DID IT COME
FROM?
WHY IS THERE SO MUCH HATE?
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS ARE
OVERWHELMINGLY GOOD PEOPLE.
IT GOES WAY BEYOND ANGER OVER
THE TRAGEDIES OF FLOYD AND TRAVE
ON MARTIN AND PHILANDO CASTILE.
THE GENESIS OF THE SEATING HE
HATRED BEGAN DECADES AGO AND IT
SPREAD LIKE A CONTAGION INTO ALL
LEVELS OF LEARNING.
RADICAL PROFESSORS ATTACKING THE
IDEALS OF WESTERN CIVILIZATION
AND IT’S ONLY GOTTEN WORSE.
YESTERDAY -- CHECK THIS OUT, ONE
PROFESSOR AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
ALABAMA PROVIDED A TUTORIAL ON
TWITTER ABOUT HOW TO PULL DOWN
NATIONAL MONUMENTS.
AND GUESS WHAT?
THE TWEET BY THE PROFESSOR IS
STILL UP ON TWITTER.
JACK DORSEY CLAIMS TRUMP’S
TWEETS ARE ENCOURAGING VIOLENCE?
THIS WOMAN IS A PROFESSOR AND
SHE’S GETTING PAID WITH THE TAX
DOLLARS THAT THE UNIVERSITY OF
ALABAMA GETS.
AND BY THE WAY, UNIVERSITIES ARE
TEAMING WITH AMERICA-HATING
INDOCTRINATE IS LIKE HER.
NOT ONLY WILL SHE NOT GET FIRED
FOR THAT, SHOULD PROBABLY GET AN
AWARD AT THE NEXT FACULTY
MEETING.
THE FINEST COLLEGES IN THE
NATION ARE PRODUCING
AMERICA-HATING AGENT PROVOCATEUR
PROVOCATEUR.
IT LIKE THIS AGGRIEVED PRINCETON
AND NYU LAW SCHOOL GRAD
CALLING -- HE WAS ALLEGEDLY
BEHIND THE WHEEL OF A TAN
MINIVAN AS HIS PASSENGER, FELLOW
ATTORNEY AND FLORIDA LAW SCHOOL
GRAD, WHEN SHE THREW A MOLOTOV
COCKTAIL INTO A POLICE CRUISER.
HATEFUL, ANTI-AMERICAN POISON IS
ALSO SPEWED IN SOME OF OUR
CHURCHES AS WELL.
WHO CAN FORGET OBAMA’S PAL,
REVEREND JEREMIAH WRIGHT, U.S.
OF KKK BRAND?
BUT ULTIMATELY THIS ALL COMES
FROM A SCUM OF THE PEOPLE.
HOW ARE WE PARENTING OUR KIDS?
ARE WE TEACHING THEM TO LOVE AND
RESPECT EVERYONE NO MATTER WHAT
RACE I’M IN A MATTER WHAT
ETHNICITY?
OUR FATHERS ON THE SCENE AT ALL.
ARE WE TEACHING OUR CHILDREN TO
LOVE OR HATE AMERICA?
ARE WE TEACHING THE BASIC RIGHT
FROM WRONG?
DON’T TAKE ANYTHING THAT’S NOT
YOURS, EVEN A PENNY?
WHEN WE DON’T TEACH THE LIGHT OF
GOD’S LOVE, WE RISK THAT OUR
CHILDREN AND OUR COUNTRY GETS
SUCKED INTO THE DARKNESS
EVENTUALLY.
THAT’S WHAT YOU’RE SEEING PLAY
OUT TONIGHT.
NOW, I CAN’T IMAGINE THAT ANYONE
WITH A BRAIN OR HALF OF ONE
WOULD WANT TO GET MIXED UP WITH
THIS CROWD.
LOOK AT THEM.
THERE PRETEND, PRIVILEGED
SOLDIERS WHO WOULD MELT IF
FORCED TO DEFEND THEMSELVES.
ULTIMATELY, THIS IS WHERE STRONG
LEADERS EMERGE, TO LEAD PEOPLE
AWAY FROM THE LAWLESSNESS, AWAY
FROM THE DARKNESS.
YET TODAY, BLUE STATE MAYORS AND
GOVERNORS HAVE FAILED TO ACT TO
CONTAIN THE MADNESS, AFRAID TO
DO SO WOULD BE POLITICALLY
INCORRECT OR SOMEHOW PORTRAY AN
ALLIANCE WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THIS IS ABOUT AMERICA,
PRESERVING HER.
AND SOME MEDIA FIGURES, BY THE
WAY, HAVE AIDED AND ABETTED THE
CHAOS.
PORTRAYING THOSE DRIVING THE
LAWLESSNESS AS SOMEHOW JUSTIFIED
IN SMASHING, GRABBING, PUSHING,
BEATING, DESTROYING, AND YES,
ULTIMATELY KILLING, THEY HOPED,
THE SPIRIT OF THIS COUNTRY.
THEY ARE PRETRADE LIKE
MODERN-DAY FREEDOM WRITERS.
VIOLATING CURFEWS AND TAUNTING
NATIONAL GUARDSMEN SHOULD BE
CELEBRATED APPARENTLY IN SOME
MEDIA OUTLETS.
THESE NEWS ANCHORS, THAT’S WHAT
YOU WANT TO CALL THEM, THEY’RE
TAKING SIDES WITH ANARCHISTS.
THAT’S HOW MUCH THEY HATE
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND ULTIMATELY
THE OLD NORMAL AS THEY SEEK TO
REPLACE IT WITH I DON’T KNOW
WHAT, SOME TYPE OF NEW NORMAL
THAT’S GOING TO BE GREAT, PEACHY
KEEN?
THEY ARE WILLING TO HELP THE
COUNTRY BURN OUT OF THEIR
OBSESSION WITH REMOVING TRUMP
FROM OFFICE.
THAT’S NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
AMERICANS ARE LOVING PEOPLE, BUT
THEY’VE HAD ENOUGH.
THEY HAD ENOUGH OF LOCKDOWNS AND
NOW THEY’VE HAD ENOUGH OF
LOOTING.
IT’S TIME TO DEFEND OUR FOUNDING
PRINCIPLES, LIFE, LIBERTY, AND
PURSUIT OF HAPPINESS.
WE DO THIS WITH RESPECT FOR OUR
FELLOW MAN, WITHOUT HER LOVE OF
GOD, AND OUR BELIEF IN THE